are you worried about your future and is
climate change one of your concerns how
about we tackle all these problems at
the same time yes it's possible that's
why the European Commission has proposed
new climate and energy targets up to
2030 by firstly cutting harmful
greenhouse gas emissions by 40% below
1990 levels with the ultimate goal of
reducing them by at least 80 percent by
2050 does this sound a bit ambitious to
you well we've already lowered our
emissions by 18 percent since 1991 our
gross domestic product has grown by 45
percent so even if fighting global
warming is a real challenge it's an
opportunity for our economy as well
first of all it will be good for
competitiveness and innovation many
sectors will develop quickly in the
coming years such as sustainable
construction clean transport
energy-efficient products renewable
energy for instance green jobs already
increased from 3 million in 2002
to 4.2 million in 2011 and that's just
the beginning
secondly by favoring renewable energy
and energy efficient solutions we also
reduce our dependence on imported energy
and with this our oil import bill which
is 1 billion euros per day the EU is not
alone in taking climate action many
countries are on the same track but
Europe is clearly leading the way from
now until 2020 at least 20% of the EU
budget will be spent on climate action
that's around a hundred and eighty
billion euros so tackling climate change
means business good business and it's
everybody's business 2030 goals for
climate and energy Europe is showing the
way towards a safe and prosperous
low-carbon future for our planet and our
economy
you